hey there i'm full of Molina and on this
channel we analyze and dissect and have
a lot of fun sharing as many little
miserable moment as we can in our
favorite nerd properties like get ready
because just like the trailer before it
start wars the force awakens the movie.!
is insanely packed with references and
easter eggs and cameos and interesting
imagery a whole sort of trivia and I'm
just preparing you because this is going..
to be a huge video but totally worth it
because there's so much cool stuff and I
definitely think we actually spotted a
few things that I haven't seen anywhere
else
oh and obviously with the movie being so
jam-packed the Attic cut a finger to the
lucky for you I've got a good idea on
what those deleted scenes were and i'll
go over those to know if you think I
miss anything feel free to let me know
in the comments but there's a good
chance we already covered it in one of
our other star wars references any
strike videos for the trailer breakdown
so check those out after this if you
want to see even more all right going in
order as it played out in the movie
let's get to it spoilers galore
starting at the beginning
the opening shot of the film which is up
there as may be one of the coolest
looking ones they've ever done shows us
a new level of Star Destroyer eclipsing
a planet star destroyers called the
finalizer and this epic ship is twice as
big as the old school star destroyers
and it actually had to be built in
secret because it really blatantly
violates the treaty between the first
order in the New Republic but since this
epic shot is also the first thing we see
you might not be surprised that there's
some interesting imagery choice is going
on here to the tip of the finalizer very
much resembles the crossguard of kylo
Ren's lightsaber and this ship with that
cross guard style mass begins to block
out all of the light in the shot almost
completely bringing darkness to the
planet below
but when there's just the tiniest sliver
of light left a few ships shoot out of
its side escaping through the light
specifically including the ship that
finish on all right JJ did a lot of this
kind of stuff in this movie moving on in
Star Wars the language we hear our main
characters speak sounds a lot like
English but they call it basic over the
first non basic words the movie are some
concern beeps from bb-8 when he sees the
first order approaching - cuckoo but the
first English or basic words that are
spoken are by Mac spots at Al's lor san
tekka and his line is this should begin
to make things right
this that's the first line of the first
Star Wars movies since the not love
three equals so another translation that
might be like damn
shots fired lor san tekka and JJ that's
an official translation
moving on when the troop transporters
carrying finlande on the stands of jakku
their design and the choreography and
the cinematography
they're all nods to the landing craft
touching down on the sands of Omaha
Beach specifically the way was depicted
in one of JJ's mentors movies Saving
Private Ryan directed by steven
spielberg in both movies we get shots of
the concerns soldiers packed into the
vessels and they can't see whether about
to land
but the moment the vessel doors lowered
the soldiers up front are immediately
killed
chaos ensues and when Finn spaces out
due to all the violence
it's almost identical to the way tom
hanks spaces out also not being able to
comprehend it all
JJ is borrowing that movie is realistic
depiction of invasion and the
surrounding tragedy to make us right out
of the gate realized these stormtroopers
are actual people who are actually dying
and that's all before we've even seen
one of them take their helmets off also
this isn't the only World War two
reference in the movie but that's later
let's keep going
the x-wing that PO jumps into but is
quickly disabled is actually not fancy
new technology it's more of a modified
version of what the rebels already had
back in the original trilogy and the
point of this reference is to show us
that the resistance isn't hot
well-funded they are working off what is
now very old technology
meanwhile the first order moments later
shows off their fancy brand new ships
when kylo Ren arrives and his personal
Luke salon class shuttle and it's twice
as big and way newer than Vader's old
lambda-class shuttle and it's obviously
like nine Greek letters better a few
moments later we see one of the most
memorable amazing moments in the movie
when kylo Ren uses his force abilities
to freeze a freaking blaster bolt midair
considering blaster bolts are kind of
like shooting lasers that's something
we've never seen the force due
manipulate light energy the way that
being freezes in the way it looks I mean
it's weird to say this but it's actually
scientifically accurate and that's
because i'm pretty sure the filmmakers
studied this actual experiment in real
life where star wars obsessed scientists
wanted to see what it would look like to
freeze a blaster bolt midair
also this new manipulating of light that
the force can do it's not our only knew
for stability but let's keep going
that's one known that the legendary John
Williams came back to compose the music
for the force awakens but that means
that JJ wasn't able to go to his go-to
composer for everything from alias two
star trek Michael chiquinho that guy is
totally great - he won the Oscar for his
score for up I can still home like every
score from Los but Aquino actually
considers John Williams to be his hero
he even said he'd rather hear new Star
Wars music from john williams then from
himself he got rewarded because he's the
Stormtrooper that pushes poe dameron
down in front of Kyle
that's a pretty good trade a few moments
later when bb-8 sees the explosion and
me things
Oh might be dead his sounds are
incredibly emotional and sad and that
makes sense considering actual humans
perform bb-8 voice you might already
know that was actually Bill Hader and
John Ralphio himself ben schwartz and it
really is their performance because what
they did is they spoke words and made
sounds into an ipad app that digitize
their voices into robotic sounds fun
Bill Hader fact he's actually a huge
star wars nerd and like 10 years ago he
was begging to be a lowly production
assistant on this star wars documentary
just because he loved it so much and i'm
also not surprised that he got the job
as bb-8 voice because a lot of people
don't remember years ago he is to go
around doing these amazing impression of
non-human Star Wars characters they're
just so good
watch your job without dying
when you're dying on you
amazing
and for Ben Schwartz I here's a video of
another time that he added his voice to
a part of Star Wars that doesn't really
use words
yeah
ok then we meet captain phasma who's our
first game is around cameo gwendoline
christie and while you probably didn't
know that a lot of people don't know
that her shiny armor
it's purposely made to stand out within
the star wars universe because she
wanted to be a symbol in star wars
history it turns out it actually melted
down from one of those Rome ships that
they use on the Emperor and Padme his
homeworld Naboo and her armor
specifically came from one of the
Emperor ship so fast my uses it as a
symbol of his power then race cabbages
and there's a specific moment where she
pulls out a salvaged old Star Destroyer
part it's a capacitor bearing but the
framing of this shot is very purposely
mirrored almost exactly in a much more
time active moment later in the movie
when Ray's pulling out parts of the
fancy new circular base and the way she
repels around these old destroy walls
it's also mimicked in her escape from
the new vessels interrogation area it's
just a bunch of setups and pay off
ready then takes her findings back on
her speeder and sure it has some
similarities to luke's speeder but it's
actually hard to place what kind of
speed it is and that's because as it
turns out rebuilt it herself from other
party scavenge fact you might not have
noticed there's no seat she's sitting on
the engine and the engine is a recycled
hot racer engine there's also other
podracer parts floating around on jakku
and the tattered podracer flags at moms
clouds castle they all give us the
detail that's pretty easy to miss in
this time of the star wars universe know
hun podraces anymore actually get that
because a silly spectator sport doesn't
make as much sense once the Emperor
takes over and everything is terrible
can't say I miss it either molecule and
the movie doesn't have a ton of nod to
the prequels but there are some then we
get another epically beautiful shot
where ray cruises past the outside of
the down star destroyer and it's
actually known to be the inflict ER it
was a story that went down back in the
battle of jakku had a whole story about
why it's crashed into that very spot in
the sand if you want to know that story
it's in the new star wars book lost
stars i'll put a link to the description
to it but when I think it's cool about
this shot and shot we get a little later
where she's standing behind a super star
destroyer
it is the first time we've actually been
able to grasp the scale of these huge
ships next to a human being it finally
gives us a relative size for all those
shots that are in space and hold
the crap that means all those battles
are so massive
Raven drags his cabin genes to unkar
plutt who seems to run things here on
email post and the actor underneath that
blob eNOS happens to be Simon Pegg his
voice was heavily altered but he's
actually really in there wearing all
that stuff
Star Wars I've burned tower only his
facial expressions were enhanced with
CGI is also fun to note that simon
Pegg's one of the stars of the new star
trek movies and he's writing the new
ones i guess you can join Finn in the
list of really likable traders when Ray
goes home and get a really good look at
her belongings including this little
rebel pilot doll that she clearly made
herself and would probably do really
well if she sold it on etsy particularly
has a thing about rebel pilots later
she's outside of her home which is a
down to 84 @ @ if you say it that way
I'll let you guys debate that in the
comments in any way when she goes out
there she puts on an old rebel flight
helmet and as she imagined what it would
be like to be a rebel pilot you can see
on the side
the star wars are best letters fresh and
and her which in english spell
r ke h as in ray not just some cute
production designer joke though the
helmets markings actually mean it
belongs to the turf in yellow aces
specifically captained Ozma tray of
female x-wing pilot so here's my theory
considering how obsessed ray is with
this pilot and her adventures and how
little she seems to know about her own
path couldn't it be the case that Ray
actually named herself after captain ray
like having forgotten her own original
name it would mirror how kylo Ren chose
to go buy a new name when he changes
identities how r n is actually been
and then ray could be bay bay Skywalker
her for bacon lb that's terrible note
forget the bay part the theory kind of
hold up no bae moving on right rescues
bb-8 from titos net and i'm pretty sure
that's the moment where Star Wars
character says job
I think Tito mutters it right there if
you don't know by the way job is this
trademark phrase of conor o'brian it
means nothing he just loves it he put it
in the simpsons of the iguana
Jeb is fantastic bag JJ to put in Star
Wars and you got jumped up in i did this
is fantastic
pretty sure that's where it is and
speaking of trademark phrases when ray
tells BBA to stay off Kelvin Ridge it's
a reference to JJ Abrams is grandfather
Henry Kelvin he actually puts that in
all of his projects it was big and lost
that's a major ship and star trek so now
you can add Kelvin Ridge to that list
that's going to finalize our PO played
by Oscar Isaac being enforced tortured
and interrogated by kylo Ren and just
outside the room is general Hawkes
played by Donald Gleason a lot of people
like to point out that Isaac's and
glisan were in a movie together about a
very advanced roid called it's mocking
up the movies great actually
I don't think it's nearly as fun as
reminding people that kylo & powered a
movie together to the movies
you pick a child about the key that
scene is equally intense back on jakku
the only quick thing worth pointing out
is that unkar plutt refers to be ba as
at him and then throughout the entire
rest of the movie people call me baji
him and they might not seem unusual
except almost all the way up until the
film's release VA was confirmed to be a
girl that's because Lucas Films
president Kathleen Kennedy referred to
her as a girl and so did the designers
of BBA so why do people keep calling to
him
they don't give us much of an answer
actually they just say that somewhere in
the design changes they change something
about bb-8 that made him definitively a
boy and like the only thing I can think
is that somewhere online they added a
wiener
like I don't know haha else they would
be able to just suddenly shift genders
thinking about it I guess they wouldn't
really want to have to explain why two
dudes were hired to do the voice of
female droid that sounds way more
possible actually then then adding a
wiener
it just it just wouldn't be practical
you can't you wouldn't be able to roll
with it was more on the finalizer we see
Finn take off his stormtrooper helmet
and revealed to PO that he's rescuing
him and it's a direct reference to loose
revealing to lay in a new hope
I'm Skywalker here to rescue you then
it's been in po try and make their
escape we get our best look at petty
officers annison he's actually game with
their own champion number two
Thomas brodie-sangster you might better
remember him as the adorably horny
little kid from love actually
unfortunately if you're a big fan of his
that's all you get because he died by 10
seconds later in that same escape seen
you actually also hear the infamous
wilhelm scream
that's in every star wars movie i Doan
fence cape on the TIE fighters and the
finalizer fires the ventral cannons we
see some really unusual blast rather
than the lasers were used to
I mean one of those things takes up the
whole side of the TIE fighter and the
thing is that this could be part of this
huge reveal in the way the first order
works now
apparently the new Star Destroyer the
finalizer it has a brand new weapon that
is very expensive and very special
because it's powered by Kyber crystals
and why that matter
Kyber crystals are what Jedi's used to
make light sabers the bad guys sit
sabers are usually made using these
knockoff synthetic crystals but not the
jedis and actually not pile of red Sabre
either but the fact that the first order
is now using weapons powered by Kyber
crystals tells us that the first order
is actually using technology
powered by the force so that means snow
kit intermingling the first order and
the dark side
way more than the original Empire ever
did which is gonna make a huge
difference when the first order is
trying to take on Jedi
also while Finn and power escaping we
get the reveal that Finn doesn't
actually have a name but rather he is
referred to by his number
fn-2187 now there's one kind of obvious
reference there because cell 2 187 is
where they found princess leia way back
on the Death Star
Curtis 127 you go again but the number 2
187 is itself a bigger reference to the
nineteen sixty three short film 2187
directed by arthur lipsett it's one of
those super artsy short films it's a
hell in black and white but it
completely inspired george lucas and is
making a Star Wars like I'm talking
droids and the force and it's just so
much stuff i would have to save it for
another video but i will point out the
way that they use the numbers in 2187
that these are some of the last words in
the short film
somebody walks up and you say your
numbers 2187 isn't it so
not that references would ever be in
competition with each other but isn't it
cool that sure in the original it was
Leila's cell on the Death Star but here
in this 2187 is exactly how people refer
to Finn and that's also the way they use
it in the short film they walk up to him
and call him number 2187 very cool
reference
moving on when phasma reports back about
fn-2187 going rogue you can seed young
fan maybe around eight or nine years old
and probably the AG was when he was
taken by the first order then as general
Hux and kylo Ren bicker like siblings
ren says that perhaps nope should have
used a clone army
it's obviously a reference to the past
days of the clone troopers based on
Jango Fett but it's also really
interesting because it's reinforcing
stormtroopers are real people but it
actually is opening up another really
interesting possibility they might not
all be human if it is the only one we've
seen take his helmet off speaking up in
he and Ray finally meet and it's very
fun and she doesn't need hand-holding
you okay for me and the two of them and
bb-8 run through this archway that marks
the entrance to the name outpost and is
actually a design that we never got to
see but was supposed to mark the
entrance to Jabba the Hutt's palace way
back in return of the jedi I'm it
actually makes a lot of sense here
though since nema i'll post was named
for NEMA the hut on Lady hunt and thank
God we didn't have to see her
also this exact same part the camera
actually pans right past the Millennium
Falcon most people just didn't notice it
oh and of course ray calling it garbage
is I call back to Luke calling it a
piece of chunks which might seem harsh
since ray collect junk for a living but
the Falcon actually is a really old
freighter ship now you can actually see
it at one point flying around in the
prequels and that's more than 50 years
before the events of this movie but at
least she's got it where it counts its
latest owner is revealed to be on guard
plot you hear him yell that's mine
a Hawaiian ray Grand Theft Auto is it
and this is a really good moment to
reveal another scene that was deleted
apparently on car actually tracks the
Falcon to tackle dan I
and maz kanata castle he then get in a
fight with our heroes and finally
something that's been teased that before
but we've never seen chewy tears is
freaking arm off
it's not wise for sort of work that's
amazing I totally hope they shot it and
it makes its way onto a blu-ray or
something because I got to see that
Wookiee yank
that's not what I mean come back to the
AC now we can see how the Falcon has
held up and it's not well at all
actually you can see the Gunners seat
that Finn's operating is really rough
and clunky and in another parallel to
New Hope's actually shot very similarly
to han and luke escape light on the
balcony they even celebrate the same way
the targeting computer is still the
exact same Nintendo Virtual board game
but we do see one clear upgrade that
somebody made there's a new antenna on
top of it because if you remember when
Lando tohon that he's gonna return to
Falcon without a scratch you almost
immediately get the antenna smashed off
the top this new little antennas
rectangular instead of round I guess the
advantage there is that parents can just
recycle the old toy they have to get the
new one with the rectangle with the bad
parents as a ray highlights the Falcons
she flies through the whole of one of
the old craft starships which is even
bigger than the massive flickr we saw
earlier and this is a super star
destroyer
it's actually what's left of the Ravager
that also went down in the battle of
jakku
it was actually the last Super Star
Destroyer the original vampire hat and
the Admiral in charge of that ship her
name was also raised a lot of raising
this neighborhood the story of that ship
is in the star wars book aftermath not
lost ours are all links that one of the
description to moving on after Rey and
Finn escape the Falcon gets pulled into
Han and Chewie these new cargo ship the
arowana and it's gonna be a really long
time before anyone can definitely see it
clearly if it's there but apparently
there's a cargo container on this ship
it is numbered 990 6 75 3
that's the same number we saw on a
different cargo crate and hangar 51 in
indiana jones in there it contains the
Ark of the Covenant it's like Harrison
Ford cannot get away from that thing
when Han and Chewie board million Falcon
we get a ton of quick nods to the
original trilogy
Brian Finn hiding out in the smuggling
compartment that Luke on and obi-wan
hidden before other also wearing the
same atmospheric mass that Han Chewie
and Leia where an empire strikes back
and that scene back then
they're out there cleaning off my not
bats who have that gross sucker mouth
that is on the glass of the Falcon and
also the rat our mouths and tentacles on
the Falcons cockpit class and also
references that Falcon famous show off
statistic about its castle run distance
but she gets wrong it says it's 14
parsecs and a million nerd shout 12 at
the same time that Honda and oh my god
is a lot of references
do you want more ok
in that same sequence we get cameras
from the really bad ass stars of the
raid as members of candy club and
seriously they're epic fighters you
should watch the raid to see that we
also get hon saying I have a bad feeling
about this and it's the third time has
said that got a bad feeling about this
really good feeling about this which
means he surpasses obi-wan to the person
who said that the most though he already
had that record if you count the time
that Indiana Jones said in Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull and the Indiana Jones
reference is go with the other direction
when they're all trying to outrun the
rat stars as one of them comes rolling
behind hon it's exactly the same framing
as the famous boulder
that's chasing indie and Raiders of the
last start and when Finn is looking for
God we find and tosses Luke training
remote droid thing and it's actually
technically Hans remote but that doesn't
matter because the references are done
and oh my god when they are on the
Falcon it's like non-stop references who
but luckily the movie takes us to our
killer bass there we get our first good
look at supreme leader Snoke albeit he's
just a giant hologram smoke is rumored
to actually only be seven feet tall
only but here it's probably just a
reference to the giant hologram of the
Emperor's and empire strikes back but
did you see that huge crater and smokes
head
there's obviously a lot about his
backstory that we don't know
moving on and get back to the Falcon
which means more references been
accidentally activate be hollow chess
game but what's actually really cool
about that moment is that it picks up
right after where the game left off in a
new hope the little guy that just got
body slam he stands back up and he
smacks the opponent over the head with a
mallet and just good for the little guy
the other really cool thing about the
game is that they actually went and shot
new stop motion animation
just like the way they did in the
original then our crew arrives to ma's
pirate castle on taco Donna and inside
that castle there's a ton of other
references in east right
in fact I bet there's gonna be so many
more revealed over time but here's what
I've got so far
the song you hear when you enter was
written and performed by Broadway's
lin-manuel Miranda and JJ Abrams himself
there's also a funny little alien who's
played
Warwick Davis warrant played wicket the
Ewok in return of the jedi he also
played two characters in Phantom Menace
it was a wall and weasel and get w names
continue because this aliens name is
wall oven a great name
remember kids that there's also a couple
of droids that are among the oldest ones
we've ever seen in Star Wars one of
which Emmy 89 kind of looks like an
ancient ancestor to c-3po it's actually
rumored to be like thousands of years
old so this might be some of the first
droid ever but onto my favorite cameo
that we see in the castle and it's right
when we walk in the camera purposely
stays with this little creature guy for
some extra time and he looks a lot like
some sort of Wolfman that's a really
slick reference to the original new hope
as in Star Wars as it was in 1977 on
special edition you see back in nineteen
ninety-seven there were the star wars
special editions and they did it again
in 2004 and in 2011 George Lucas just
kept going back to the original trilogy
and updating the effects and changing a
bunch of scenes and adding a bunch of
CGI and that's why somehow hayden
christensen is in a movie that was
released in 1983 and how hon went from
shooting grito first to shooting in
self-defense
so for the most part this is the moment
when people started really hate on
George Lucas and his unnecessary cgi
update one of the mascots of the anti
special edition movement was the
original mas Eisley cantina Wolfman and
most people watching this video right
now and finally never even seen this guy
that's because Lucas Films is that
everything possible i can to erase them
in any reference to him from existence
they replaced him with two different
aliens in the original movie but JJ here
is very subtly sharing how he feels
about those special editions changes he
makes it super clear he thinks the
practical wolfman belongs in a cantina
scene he reinforces that practical
effects preference when you realize
aside from Moscow not herself every
character in this entire scene is a
practical as a non CGI character and to
really point that out this scene
actually opens with an almost
in it long single take uncut shot
showing us all of them really cool
oh and after that uncut tracking shot we
get our quick
Judah Friedlander cameo and he's also
not cgi he just Judah Friedlander in
space
now all this stuff in math kannada is
clearly obviously just packed with
references but it makes you wonder what
stuff we didn't see because as it turns
out this is another sequence that had a
ton cut out of it one of the deleted
scenes hasret gaining some extra wisdom
from this priest like figure his name
proster online but he was totally cut
out of the movie but even more drastic
ma's herself had this entire storyline
that was also completely cut out it's
because JJ realized that ultimately even
if she continued on with our heroes she
didn't actually need to be there with
that so don't you cut the whole thing
out and you can actually see a remnant
of maza storyline in that one shop in
the trailers where she's handing Luke's
lightsaber to Leia instead of thin
oh and as for deleted Leia scenes yeah
there were major deletions but we will
get back to that one of the most talked
about scenes is raised force vision and
that makes total sense because there's a
lot going on there you can actually hear
Vader's breathing
not just at the beginning of the vision
but there are hints of it before she's
even got into that room with the
lightsaber and then once the vision
starts added to the breathing is Luke
screaming no
he finds out that matters is dad
and that all goes with the location that
Ray is seen because that's the exact
place on Cloud City where luke and vader
had their epic fight then just before we
see all the Knights of Ren we seek
high-low stab someone through the chest
with this saber but if you watch it
closely it almost seems like that person
might have been about to attack someone
so there's a slight chance that run was
actually saving someone with that attack
let me know what you think about that
when you re watch that scene
up next in the vision a large figure
polls young railway and that bulbous
hand and that deep voice saying quiet
girl it all seems to be very likely
unkar plutt so that could mean that he's
actually not such a bad guy or that
whoever left her with them just didn't
know what a jerk he be then right at the
end of the vision if you keep your ears
open here both a young and old obi-wan
with Alec Guinness is voice saying ray
and you and mcgregor saying these are
the first step that's so awesome they
had you and come in and record new lines
just for that but with the late Alec
Guinness they use this moment from
obi-wan saying afraid it'll be afraid
and they chopped it down so that Sir
Alec could savory very cool and one of
my favorite things they did it was just
a worth hearing his voice again now also
somewhere else in there you're supposed
to be able to hear Yoda's voice saying
energy around behind but for the life of
me I've seen the movie like four times
now i have not been able to make it out
let me know in the comments if you hear
it and exactly where it is known about
this whole psychic vision thing that's
happening here with Ray that's all a
very specific but new to the movies Jedi
power called psychometry we're touching
an object allows a force-user to see
visions of the objects memories and also
just happen to the past and future and
it's a really big deal and Star Wars
actually and that's because almost no
one has ever had that power so it lends
credence to Ray being a very special
type of Jedi also really interesting to
note is that the few Jedi that have had
that power were banned from using it
because being able to see through the
eyes of others and witness extreme
violence you guessed it Jedi's believe
that lets the dark Sider so potential
storyline for Bray in the future maybe I
don't know
okay up next we have the
very crazy angry general Hux speech and
this section after the opening
stormtrooper seen its are other major
world war two reference this whole thing
is very closely modeled after the
speeches of Adolf Hitler not just the
screaming and the uniforms but the body
language the colors the troop formations
and really blatantly the stormtroopers
arms shooting up highly Huck's Nazis
have actually always been the main
inspiration for the Empire and Hitler's
rise to power is very similar to the way
the Emperor did force awakens actually
picks up where that left off because
after World War too many Nazis went into
hiding in Argentina and that's almost
exactly what happens after the Empire
shatter their remnants also go into
hiding in Argentina now getting high in
the unknown region of the galaxy where
they could all go be evil and be the new
republic would notice also the way the
first order takes young children and
then they basically brainwash them into
believing all there to get nonsense and
then they turn them into storm troopers
at all is all pretty much exactly what
the Nazis did with the Hitler Youth
enough not these
ok I let's talk about what happens after
the speech they use Starkiller base to
destroy the hosnian system including
javi and prime which is the capital of
the New Republic and since we've seen
how it works that's the first time that
a star has been utilized in an act of
war in a Star Wars movie and it's called
the hosnian system as a reference to the
famed Los Angeles high school teacher
Jim hosny who taught film to like
everybody in Hollywood when they were
teens including all of JJ Abrams is
regular producing partners Brian Burke
who produced this movie where two or chi
and alex kurtzman who co-produced the
star trek movies with JJ money even
taught the son of lawrence kasdan who
co-wrote this movie and return of the
jedi and empire strikes back so i guess
all these people just felt like they
owed this old high school teacher
something so they named an entire star
system after him and then they blew it
up anyway back to the destroyed New
Republic capital we actually only get
this really brief shot of it before it's
going out except that one shot is a
remnant of another huge story line that
was totally cut out of the
movie and it's the big layer storyline
that I alluded to earlier
so in that one shot of her husband and
prime the camera focuses on this girl
that you might have wondered is she
important out did we see here before
well she used to be important that's
course LOL and i'm gonna save a lot of
these smaller details for another video
but basically in the time that passed
since returned to the Jedi the New
Republic really desperately wanted to
pretend that everything was fine you
want to ignore it in the first order was
doing it even though it was breaking all
these treaties that they had established
Princess Leia originally was seen as
this kind of hero when she kept pointing
out how stupid it was to ignore the
first order everyone in the Senate kind
of started to hate her and it definitely
stopped trusting her so that's why I
layer formed a resistance separate from
the New Republic and there was a whole
story line in the movie that explained
all that in it now generally I feels
that she finally has enough proof to the
New Republic to act and send their fleet
to take out the first order or arrest
them or do something because they know
that they're building this insane weapon
but since she knows that no one in the
New Republic trust her anymore she had
to send one of our commanders forcella
to meet with the New Republic Senate to
convince them to prepare for war would
you like anything at all
yeah all of this stuff was comfort I'm
and they were also scenes in it where we
learned that he Threepio is in charge of
these droids that spy on the first order
Leia gives a passionate feet to her
troops there's all kinds of characters
and leaders of Naboo whole new
chancellor and it's all gone
we do however know how the story line
and because we see the killer son being
hit hard and Prime and there's course
Alice screaming he's standing next to
the new chancellor and yet proof there
there
if you thought the movie was missing a
bit of
the three politics of the New Republic
or lay up being a really badass general
keep your fingers crossed for the
deleted scenes because I think that's
all in there
ok so then later when the first order
attacks Moses castle hon uses chuys
broadcaster and even though he actually
used it a little earlier in the movie
find out that these two times like the
only times han has ever used chewy
signature weapon and when he sees that
it can blow a freaking stormtrooper
across the battlefield of course yeah
he's a big fan of it later when the
storm troopers surround chewy and hard
and have them put their hands up it's
all a call back to with the moment
return of the jedi where the same thing
happens except here the resistance comes
to the rescue and back then it was a
bunch of teddy bears or he walks oh and
in this epic rescue sneak attack we get
a moment where finn watches po flying it
says that that's one hell of a pilot and
yeah he is
because in that 22nd uncut shot ho takes
out & Tie Fighters and three storm
trooper
if you've ever heard of the concept of
an ace pilot is defined as a pilot who
has shot down at least five enemy planes
over the course of their career so that
means PO is the double ace pilot in just
these 20 seconds yeah he's definitely
one of the best pilot ever
and considering the gift that Luke gave
his family and the comic book shattered
Empire
there's a chance that there's actually
some force at work in po link to that
story in the description -
and then when we finally do get laying
in this movie how she arrives in a
modified version of a B wing from Return
of the Jedi and it's actually another
ship it's not like a new version it's
been cobbled together from parts left
over from the original trilogy and it
really underlines that the resistance
doesn't have nice anything like all of
their stuff is left over from the
Galactic Civil War even their leaders
then right after she lands we get is
really easy to miss cameo right before
han and Leia even talk we see what seems
like a standard protocol droid but if
you look closely it's actually c-3po
of course you probably don't recognize
them because of the red arm ok no I'm
kidding yes i know you can recognize the
but did you know that the red arm is
going to get its own story in another
part of the saga
apparently has to do with a sacrifice
that another droid made
and talking about it makes c-3po very
sad and it's kinda feels like three
people got like really close to another
droid while are two was asleep and I
mean jerk
good for him it is legal matter anyway
once the gang goes over to the secret
resistance face back on the car to get a
few more cameos including carrie
fisher's daughter Billie lourd can along
from Los and JJ zone good luck charm
Greg Grunberg who's been pretty much
everything Jay does he even snuck a man
at her stepdad and star trek that Carson
it with your friends but here he snap
Wesley a grownup version of 10 min
Wexley from that Star Wars aftermath
book the most interesting thing there is
that in the book it doesn't come out and
say it but it leaves you with the
feeling that he could have some of the
force in him so let's just keep an eye
on snap as the movies keep coming out oh
and that doctor who is like hardcore
flirting with two weeks he's like column
all brave and stuff cheese lady
Shackleton from Downton Abbey but more
interesting she's the niece of
christopher lee who played Count Dooku
now she's Chuy's girlfriend which is
just asking for trouble with Mars also
the resistance base here looks almost
identical to the rebel bases in the past
and it's like oh god the resistance just
need some new funding then went on a
layer talking about their son who has
been seduced by the dark side she says
there is still light in him I know which
is almost an exact quote of her mama
Padme saying about Anakin in kind of
both those references to loop thing
about Vader there is to creating and
it's interesting that Luke and Padme are
saying it to obi-wan and here later
saying it to Hans kinda like that will
be one of this movie
then after kylo has kidnapped play
and force infiltrate your mind it's
worth pointing out that he sees her
dreams of a place that has a vast ocean
and an island which exactly describes
where ray Fiennes Luke at the end of the
movie also interesting despite kylo
being the ultimate fan boy it's actually
ray who brings up darth vader and she's
the only person to mention that name in
this movie his presence is definitely
everywhere and his presence and this is
around we're very famously pulls a Jedi
mind trick on a stormtrooper and it's
actually only the fifth time we've seen
that work in the seventh movie so far
and the Stormtrooper just so happens to
be played by daniel craig i'll say his
voice down
super American actually so it's a pretty
easy to miss but his character's name is
a little less subtle it's jb
double-oh-seven back on the car the
resistance starts their plan to attack
Starkiller base and we get lots of
glimpses that all the characters whose
teams were cut out sorry to them but we
also get reintroduced a little 9 number
who last Co piloted the Falcon with
Lando
we also get everybody's favorite
modelling admiral ackbar and while it
was really awesome to see him it cannot
believe that they didn't have a car come
running out when r 2 and vba put their
star charts together and have him
yelling it's a map missed opportunity if
you ask me
back over on circular base after Ray has
escaped we get a nice little tour of the
facility and it's just interesting to
note how you can see lots of places
where the mechanical structures give way
to natural rock formations in the holes
and it really helps illustrate that
store killer bass is not just some
man-made weapon it's actually carved out
of the rock of this already existing icy
world we just never learned the planets
original named after the Falcon gets
through the shield and lands on circular
base there was another deleted scene
that has no troopers searching the
Falcon but you do get to see those snow
troopers for like literally less than
three seconds on the base and their
costumes are exactly the same designs
that were meant to be used way back on
top and empire but they didn't end up
getting used until now
then we find out that fit as a janitor
and that's not just a good setup for a
wife and knows about the trash compactor
it actually answer is a big question
posed in the famous nerd analysis movie
clerks take the average stormtrooper
knows that install a toilet me
closing that was killing and white
uniforms and now we know
yeah actually storm troopers have low
level non war-related specialties like
sanitation side note the director of
clerks is kevin smith and he's a huge
star wars nerd and he's got a voice
credit in the force awakens somewhere i
just have not been able to find it let
me know if you know where it is up above
in the air attack on Starkiller base we
get some great shots of resistance pilot
a little at sea and that's a reference
to
hello nasty the Beastie Boys album that
Jade a big fan of it has the
intergalactic on it which is a really
good fit better than a sabotage tongue
Houston star trek his helmet also says
in our bash born to ill which is the
combination of the born to kill helmet
from full metal jacket and license till
the first 50 boy studio album damn JJ
like two loves the Beastie Boys and
another resistance pilot just pava is
actually introduced in the book the
weapon of a Jedi where she's like super
into loop link below but the actress
jessica hand wiki marks our third game
of throne cameo you might remember her
as one of the sand snakes from Dorne
who's like really into whips
also when you re watch the sequence
after chewy has told hon that he's cold
pay extra attention to Han and fins
jacket it's very subtle but we make sure
that even though he's cold his old
friend Han gets his jacket bag and at
some point it seems like Finn has
learned from this because he's given his
new friend Ray his jacket and is
ever-changing jacket thing just a nice
way to show the growing relationship
between Finn and Ray as it compares to
Han and chewy but it's actually probably
something that we see a lot more of in
another deleted scenes in this 102 we
have got to set the charges for the
bombs but rain Finn have to go to a
different part of the base to give Han
and Chewie access in order to get there
quickly ran Finn steal another vehicle
they take out some snow troopers and
raised shows off more piloting of their
snow speeder and you can actually still
see the snowspeeder in the background
just before they run back into the base
another interesting choice and JJ's
imagery is less settled in the opening
shots but it's still pretty cool when
Hans talking to Kyle oh and the light on
Kyle his face changes from light to
darkness and then his entire face gets
cast
red light like the fifth color just as
his descent into the dark side is
complete it might not be the most subtle
imagery but it's just straight up a cool
way to tell us information without
having to explain it just literally with
dialogue also in this moment where the
spoiler spoiler for the how are you
still watching the TV care about
spoilers a moment where Han guys you'll
note that Rey and Finn have to watch
their mentor type be struck down by a
lightsaber and it all just mirrors
pretty exactly Luke watching Vader kill
obi-wan
and also again it makes hon this movie
adobe wall then hands body falls down
into the void and it's reminiscent of a
bunch of other Star Wars falling deaths
including Darth Maul mace windu overfed
the Emperor kind of similar to Luke
falling in Empire Strikes bag mostly
similar to the Emperor and dark more
accepted you know Darth Maul didn't
actually die then
very crazy it for another time . it was
the following they got it started having
safety nets or something
ok moving on then pin and eventually ray
have some pretty badass duels with kylo
out in the snow and man about the way
light sabers at night melting the snow
that was all very cool but also cool is
the fighting style that they're using it
actually lifted from the original
trilogy despite modern technology being
able to recreate all the lips and
parkour and fancy stuff they did in the
prequels it actually makes sense that in
both the original trilogy and now in
force awakens no Jedi have actually got
in the level of training that allows for
all those fancy moves even Luke never
gets that great at handstands know in
their universe it does make a lot of
sense that this is a battle of mostly
brute force and now jabbing style of the
tag a prequel fighting so much has been
done a long time
also another reference despite being her
kyle is actually trying a very cocky
one-handed style of fighting he's
mimicking Darth Vader's form when he was
toying with Luke that cockiness just
doesn't work out quite as well for Kyle
and moments later when the lightsaber is
stuck in the snow and Ray force Yanks it
out it's a lot like how Luke did it in
the beginning of empire there's a much
more interesting reference going on here
to a very old but very legendary tale
that actually inspires a lot of this
entire movie but since we're almost done
i'm just going to point out very quickly
some of the last Easter eggs and
references before i go into that include
trench run much like the one in New Hope
but just for a moment where pose flying
in the trenches Starkiller base and
after the win in the celebration back
onto car but just before you see layout
flying solo at the bottom of the screen
you'll see just a little glimpse of our
- Katie a pink version of r2d2 that was
created by star wars fan Alvin Johnson
has a tribute to his daughter Katie who
unfortunately died by
in 2005 but by putting the droid in this
movie she now has a legacy as big as
Star Wars and then the star map that
bb-8 and r2 d2 put together is actually
very specific style of map it existed in
knights of the old republic these maps
are very special they're very old a
chart many systems that there's no other
record of and these maps might even have
connections to the force itself so
they're really fancy maps
finally the last basic language words of
the film are
may the force be with you but the actual
final lines of the film
just like the first ones are series of
beeps and whistles
except instead of bb-8 from r2 d2 me
good okay returning to the huge
reference that is going on throughout
the entire movie
let's go back to that battle in the snow
that rate had a vision of before this
entire story of hers and kylo Ren's is
very reminiscent to the tales of King
Arthur
the force awakens actually gives us all
sorts of little references to that time
. remember when high-low Ren's
lightsaber was first unveiled there was
all that attention paid to the
crossguard that's because that's
something we've never seen a lightsaber
before but it's very common in medieval
broadsword also kylos appearance is
similar to that of King Arthur's nemesis
Mordred the shaggy hair the dark clothes
it's actually looked at seen a lot in
medieval warden type characters kind of
like Jon Snow is or I the Sheriff of
Nottingham also some other uniquely
medieval references include a castle
that covered in old banners
stormtroopers using shields kylos men
being referred to as knights and knights
of ren even feel like the knights of the
round table that surround King Arthur
except they think I love arthur and the
wrong all in one of his other soldier
types where's the metallic armor other
night but back to being mistaken about
him ordered isn't the chosen one and
neither is kylo just like in King
Arthur's origin the chosen one is
actually the young poor orphan ty still
kind of think the lightsaber or sword is
his birthright
especially because there's an evil
practitioner of dark magic snowboard
Morgan la Fey and Arthur stories
misleading here but when the swords last
saber is placed in stone or in this case
know the one
who thinks it's his birthright can't get
it out instead the sword will only go to
the true chosen one a young Arthur or in
our case right now pulling the sword out
of the stone man Arthur was destined to
become king so we'll see what that means
for Ray but it's also worth noting that
a lot of those are 30 and stories a lot
of versions of it Mordred and Arthur are
related so that could be a clue to Ray
and wrens relationship it's also worth
noting that a lot of people have used
this same comparison to describe the
original trilogy with luke and vader and
those roles and the Emperor as the
Morgan la Fey type and actually i'll say
that even if that's the case it also
works because if you say Luke is
actually King Arthur well in those
stories when Arthur is gravely hurt his
mythical sword Excalibur is sent flying
into the hands of the old and wise lady
of the lake she holds a sword for
safekeeping until it died there needed
again until Arthur is time to return
with Mars is our lady of the lake she
not only sees that the sword is needed
again giving it to Ray but it also makes
its way back to the original King Arthur
to mark his return when Bray hands it to
Luke
oh also remember where mazza's castle is
yeah she lives on a lake
ok that was fun and a holy crap so many
freaking observations and reference
histo actually what the hell one more
quick observation right at the end when
we see Luke before ray has interrupted
him and before he looks away it looks
like he's looking at a gravestone lot of
theories rajita you tell me what you
think that could be about it in the
comments and let me know anything else
you think I might have missed
I didn't leave out some things that I
didn't find too interesting but some
other stuff is in those other trailer
breakdown videos that i mentioned so
check those out or any other videos that
you might interest you there's a lot of
them but if you like this video make
sure to share it i think there's some
really good stuff here so it's a good
share
huh I've until milena you can follow me
on twitter at fimo and follow this
channel for video updates at new rock
stars subscribe if you want to see more
stuff like this in your feed regularly
because this is what I live for
this is what we make as for me I'm just
gonna go see Star Wars again
I know their stuff that I'm still
missing and I'm just so mad I haven't
heard the yoda line
clearly I gotta go bye